maintenant on va avait demandé à kelly à
la savate et 10 parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens sur les réseaux qui disent on a
hâte de voir qu'est d'y aller danser ça
m'a tellement à lhassa attention la
musique soul et c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
ok ok alors
j'ai des personnes sur les réseaux
sociaux qui me disait ce qu'on peut
faire tout le titre est ce qu'on peut
mettre tout l'album dallas nakamura oui
c'est parce que vous en voulez encore
plus en plus sensuelle met un truc voilà
c'est ça c'est pas bon label epas ancien
cime et l'appui on peut faire mieux
alesi ils sont en train de chercher
[Musique]
hier
comment
[Musique]
tc ex-travail bords des longs ballons